[Musique]
aujourd'hui samedi 22 janvier au qg de
campagne de valérie pécresse nous avons
avec plusieurs parlementaires réunis à
la demande de valérie pécresse de très
nombreux professionnels de santé et de
très nombreux étudiants en santé ce
qu'ils vont faire l'avenir du système de
santé avait trois tables rondes la
première avec les jeunes comment voit-il
leur profession dans les 10 20 30 ans ce
sont eux qui vont nous soigner ensuite
avec les patients parce qu'il n'y a pas
de système de santé qui fonctionne si on
ne prend pas en compte la question des
patients leurs attentes
le fait qu'ils apportent beaucoup au
système de santé on a vu durant de cette
épidémie que le traitement par exemple
de l'épidémie aurait été bien différent
si on avait pris en compte les attentes
de toutes ces hommes et ces femmes qui
vivaient dans les ehpad et puis
troisième point la question de
l'innovation un grand pays c'est un pays
qui innovent
il n'y a pas de santé moderne s'il n'y a
pas d'innovation alors nous avons écouté
nous avons discuté avec tous ces
intervenants et nous en sommes arrivés à
plusieurs conclusions et une de ses
conclusions c'est qu'une santé une
politique de santé moderne c'est une
politique de santé globale qui prend
tout en compte la médecine de ville
l'hôpital le médico-social les ehpad
mais aussi l'air que vous respirez
l'alimentation de vous manger la santé
animale la santé environnementale c'est
tout ça la sortie si la santé globale
c'est une manière moderne peut voir les
choses et de faire de la politique voilà
ce que nous avons appris de cette
journée
[Musique]